Taylor Swift it debuts a new do you  never know what it's going to be the  singer dropped by model Liberty Ross his  birthday bash over the weekend and  showed off her new look in the party's  of photo booth the star has a shagger  cuttin were used to plus some major  bangs hair stylists Gareth Bramall  posted more pics with Swift revealing  that the darker hue she's rocking is  courtesy of celebrity hair maven at  Traci Cunningham you have a very famous  blonde tirage of devoted celebrity  clients for blondes who are some of the  top one my blondes are charlize Gwyneth  Cameron drew january jones the best  blondes the fest but back to that party  Taylor enjoyed the evening alongside  stars including James Corden America  Blige a Mick Jagger and the Haim sisters